you
everyone is cherry I'm on chest calm
right now I just went into tactics
trainer and I'm gonna try three puzzles
and just share my thoughts along the way
so right on cue I don't know how well
you have your volume turned up the
beagle those of you who have watched
more than one video have likely come
across the beagle in my videos he is
back out making an appearance but okay
white to move in this one he seems to
time it just right let me tell you okay
my first thought is was actually 9 g5
it's quite forcing Tyrael count hmm
let's see it's a bunch of thoughts
running through my mind right now in
fact one that comes to mind is the what
type of opening this came from anyhow
might be like a French this Bishop did a
little zigzag over here anyhow material
white is down material one two three
four five six down a couple pawns whites
down a couple pawns so I'm not so
excited about this move anymore really
you could pick up the brook taking
advantage of this pin but night check
King here well hang on for a moment
night check King cannot go to g7 because
of night here however after a night
check King to g8 I don't know how great
a follow-up there would be I think I'm a
bit more tempted to first take the
bishop and remove this defender of the
King side and then we could introduce a
new piece into the position the rook on
a one that's currently not doing a whole
lot so if ruk takes here which is quite
the forceful move you have to pretty
much take him right back if roof takes
King takes rook g1 check hmm there's
only King to h7 Queen g5 we just take so
rook takes Bishop King takes rook rook
g1 check King h7 now it's much different
Knight g5 only at that point and then
it's big trouble for black if the King
goes to h8 Knight takes rook just wins a
flat out rook and it would actually turn
out to be a fork and after Knight g5 the
King goes to any of these three there's
gonna be that discovered check so I
believe that's it just being a bit
cautious recognizing the material
deficit to start on the white side and
well now going in for Knight g5 right
away okay let's see if we got it we do
that is the correct move and this was my
idea
that to is correct and now finally maybe
the puzzle will end at this point not
quite okay it's gonna make us play out
one more move but that was the correct
idea to first remove that Bishop and
invite the new piece into the attack and
then finally basically drop the bomb on
the position with Knight g5 okay puzzle
- coming up team black huh alright first
thought is that white as a mate threat
here there's no time for pawn takes
knight material count hmm I wonder where
do we stand with that we're up upon
black is up upon in this position let's
see hmm I think I see the answer here
let me try to explain my thought process
right there just kind of came to me I'm
looking for a way to not just be
strictly defensive of the f7 pawn I want
to be I want to combine
defense with a little bit of aggression
in this case I'm noticing that any
defensive move of the f7 pun will
automatically throw some threat at white
pawn takes Knight will be back on but
doing some just doing something like
this strictly defensive move this does
allow for Knight takes pawn so I'm
looking for a way to basically defend f7
and still keep this threat in mind and I
could even go one step further I believe
it's important to put pressure on this
night the move that I'm alluding to here
is Queen to c7 which is really doing
everything defends f7 first and foremost
defends the pun so it does not allow
Knight takes pawn here and should the
knight avoid capture by the pawn we're
gonna be able to snip this Knight here
you know that's not even needed the this
pressure on the knight in as much as
defense of f7 and defensive c4 I think
this is the main point here with the
Queen playing to c7 if it was the case
that let's say there was an extra
defender over here if this bishop was on
g3 then that would be all the more well
that would be one additional reason to
go to c7 defense of f7 c4 and pressure
on the night hunt I'm pretty sure this
is it this is really the only move I'm
giving consideration to there's no
checking moves I didn't do a quick scan
for that at the start there's no
checking moves so we could castle but
that's strictly defensive allows a
knight takes pawn I believe it's Queen
c7 let's run with it it is correct and
ok that wasn't the most exciting of
puzzles let's see if we could finish up
with actually an end game puzzle I'd
like to see an endgame puzzle and look
at that oh nice ok
team white what do you do when your
opponent is one move away from
queening and you don't have a dark
square bishop that can try to stop this
pond from queening hmm okay well this
really feels like an endgame study so we
could here we could be here for a while
rook check is my first thought yeah rook
check one thought I have is there's not
going to be some stalemate trick
sometimes there's a way to organize your
pieces or some sequence of moves where
you could eventually force some tricky
stalemate situation and what's telling
me that is that I don't see a way that
we could really force black to capture
this pun or anything like that this pawn
will always be able to move my time
assuming there should be some win here
rook check is the first move I believe
you just must go with that what I'm
considering now is really what blacks
options would be going to e1 would not
be good it because it allows rook here
we take the pawn and we're in position
to stop this guy and soon enough we'll
push the Queen similarly going here to
e3 after rook d7 check King to e3 hmm we
could play rook here however what would
we do after like King to f4 or King to
d4 don't really get that
tricky tricky puzzle another question I
have is what would we do if let's say
rook check King here hmm d7 King c3 I
mean we could come back over look check
then came back here is the best we can
do on the white side a draw
hmm I haven't really determined that yet
it will be white either drawing or
winning that's the usual case that's
always the case really with the puzzles
whoever's turn it is to move it's going
to be a win or a draw so I haven't
really determined that yet I don't
believe it's a bishop move to start any
bishop move black promotes mm-hmm it's
not good let's see how that could be
good so rook check okay if the King
comes over here we can keep giving
checks and in response to the checks if
the King isn't coming back to B 2 or D
to rook d7 king c3 rook cease rook c7
check if the King doesn't play the beats
who are d2 we'd play our rook to c1 and
be in position to stop the poem rook d7
king c3 hang on I'm seeing something now
I'm actually seeing something now Wow on
rook d7 king c3 I think there's a sneaky
move hmm yeah rip d7 King c3 there's no
rook d3 trying to help this bishop get
into the game on rook d7 king c3 rookie
d3 check King takes rook allows Bishop
to b5 check and then we get to pick up
this e to pond it's also worth noting
that in that position
if rook d7 king c3 rook d3 check King
takes rook Bishop b5 king d4 Bishop
takes pawn king c5 the king will be
there in time to stop the pun but
fortunately for white white does have
the correct queening square light square
so white will be able to eventually
after mopping up the H pond and e pond
he'll be able to push through to win to
to Queen that rook upon he has the
correct color Bishop so I haven't
considered everything just yet that's
just one variation starting still with
rook d7 rip d7 King c3 rook d3 and well
if the rook isn't captured the Brooke
gets behind the pun so I think I have
that down pat rook d7 king c2 will allow
Bishop a4 check and then rook to d1 the
pawn could take the rook but the bishop
is there to recapture and then this pond
will push through soon so have that
covered rook d7 I have king c3 covered
king c2 covered what about King c1 huh
on king c1 this is a very clever puzzle
it must be a study on king c1 bishop
still plays here and on the pawn
promoting rook d1 with the fork of the
king and queen all right so I knocked
out this one King c3 is covered king c2
king c1 I know what I'm doing I'm king
to e1 this one here is still well
earlier it was a little bit fuzzy after
rook d7 King III maybe I can still do
this that's probably the case rookies
King III this is probably the variation
lied I can I don't know if I could say
that I was going to say this is probably
the variation that the computer will
test me on but let's see if I have a
good answer to rook d7 King III I'm
thinking rook a d3 similar to when the
King moves to c3 rook d7 King III rook
d3 check if King takes same story Bishop
b5 check what if the King goes to f2 we
would play to d2 and pick up the pond
that since the pawns in a pin and what
about King to e4 King e4 there would be
bishop check King to f4 allows for
Brooke f4 check and then the rook gets
to e3 and I believe there's one last
variation rook d4 King III rook d3 check
King f4 what would be right my reply to
that this is the one that I'm still
trying to pitch her rook d7 King III
rook d3 check King f4 now
okay this one has me a bit stumped what
I would do exactly I'm not I'm not able
to picture it as well as I would like
right now rook d7 King III rook d3 so my
rook is on d3
their king is on f4 how hard can that be
it could be pretty hard let's see what
would I do from there I'm trying to find
a way to combine to coordinate my bishop
and rook somehow I could play like
Bishop to h5 and if the pawn promotes I
don't see what I would do there buff I'm
determined to get this rook d7 King III
Brooke at d3 check maybe it's not rook
to e3 check hmm second-guessing myself
because this is another option but then
it allows and then it allows for this
move efore I was considering rook dthe
rook d7 King III roca d5 however after E
for oh where do you go from there
I still feel like it must be rook d7
King III rook d3 king f4 but now what Oh
rook to f3 check similar idea
this is definitely an endgame study if
King takes rook the bishop comes over
here similar idea skewering the king in
the pond giving check when the King
moves you pick up the pond
alright I've spent enough time
rook d7 King III rook d3 of King F 3
give a check here and if King here you
give I mean try this one more time
rook d7 king d3 rook d3 check if King f4
we give check on f3 any other move
besides King to e4 would play over to e
3 and if King to e4 we would do what
exactly
Bishop c6 check King to d4 my goodness
rook d3 check and then finally were able
to sneak behind that pond next or still
end up with a skewer my goodness this
was a monster there was a lot of
different variations to calculate that
is correct it is going with this rook d3
check King there rook f3 check that is
correct
Bishop check King there and now finally
this rook d3 check King takes finally
this and again if the King had gone here
do know that we do have in the end the
correct pawn there to go ahead and push
through to Queen my goodness
that took a while I'm glad I was
actually successful with that I'm almost
certain that that was an endgame study
and they are without question quite
difficult to uh figure out many a times
ok anyhow feel free to share how you did
with these three puzzles in the comment
section below and I will catch you in
the next video take care bye
you